[Aplausos]
[Música]
y la rusia es un país conocido por ser
la última dictadura de europa y diréis
ya están otra vez los de visual política
llevando a dictadura a todo aquello que
no se pliega a los intereses del
capitalismo pues no hasta el propio
dictador de bielorrusia reconoce que lo
es atentos
es mejor ser un dictador que gay declara
el presidente de bielorrusia y ya sé lo
que estaréis pensando muchos pero cómo
va a ser bielorrusia una dictadura si
acaban de tener elecciones sí amigos de
visual político el 9 de agosto de 2020
los vuelos rusos fueron a las urnas como
hacen cada cinco años y por sexta vez
consecutiva a alexander lukashenko ganó
y diréis por cuánto el 51 por ciento
sesenta por ciento setenta por ciento
pues nada menos que el 80 por ciento
como os podéis imaginar este resultado
es más falso que el alma de judas y lo
cierto es que no es ni la primera ni la
segunda vez este hombre ha trucado
tantas elecciones que es que ya no se
molestan en disimular
[Música]
hemos manipulado las últimas elecciones
el 93% voto por lukashenko pero dicen
que no es un resultado europeo así que
lo hemos bajado al 86 por ciento
alexander lukashenko después de las
elecciones del 2006 habéis oído bien
lukashenko es más un dictador es el
clásico malo de película de james bond
megalómano sediento de poder y carente
de escrúpulos quedaos con esto porque
luego nos va a servir para entender
mejor la situación de bielorrusia pero
volvamos con nuestra historia en agosto
de 2020 los bielorruso han tenido de
nuevo elecciones como ya viene siendo
tradición en estos parajes la candidata
de la oposición ha tenido que marcharse
del país y los detractores de lukashenko
han salido a la calle y muchos de ellos
ya están en la cárcel de cuánta gente
hablamos y en presos 500 presos pues
nada menos que seis mil setecientos
detenidos según las propias autoridades
bielorrusas entre ellos menores de edad
y creo que a ninguno os va a sorprender
si os digo que las cárceles bielorrusas
son el último lugar donde querríais
estar
dentro de una celda de aislamiento a
decenas de hombres se les dijo que se
desnudaran y se pusieran a cuatro patas
mientras los oficiales los pateaban y
golpeaban con porras
pero ya sé lo que estaréis pensando esta
película ya la hemos visto tenemos una
ex república soviética donde los
derechos humanos son opcionales de
repente ocurre un evento político que
saca a cientos de miles de personas a la
calle el gobierno reprime las protestas
con violencia no suena esta historia de
algo exacto es lo mismo que pasó en el
año 2014 en ucrania os acordáis de las
protestas del euro maidán y os acordáis
de cómo terminaron exacto
vladimir putin invadió crimea para
evitar que el país se fuera de su área
de influencia caos de los famosos
hombrecillos verdes así que la pregunta
que hoy nos hacemos es de verdad
bielorrusia puede ser una democracia
mandará a putin al ejército para
defender a lukashenko es bielorrusia la
nueva ucrania hoy vamos a responder a
estas preguntas pero antes antes tengo
que daros una noticia que probablemente
ya sepáis y es que hemos creado un nuevo
canal de youtube y os va a flipar se
llama megaproyectos conca de visual
político en este canal
enrique alberto y yo os vamos a hablar
de los proyectos más ambiciosos de la
historia de la humanidad
[Música]
en menos de 50 años la humanidad pasó de
comunicarse entre la mayoría de las
partes más importantes del mundo a
través de cartas transportadas en barcos
a comunicarse por telégrafo con el paso
de los años el b 52 estratos for 3 se ha
convertido en mucho más que un simple
avión es algo así como un castillo
volante por ejemplo es el proyecto de la
estación espacial
freedom anunciado por ronald reagan
durante su discurso del estado de la
unión si os gusta la ingeniería este
canal os va a encantar todos los guiones
tienen una investigación detallada
detrás y podréis entender cómo se han
llevado a cabo grandes megaproyectos
como la presa de las tres gargantas en
china o el cable telegráfico
transatlántico esperamos que os guste
tanto como a nosotros y ahora sí vamos a
ver un poco de historia
aquí curamos el coronavirus con el vodka
a estas alturas todos hemos oído las
teorías más peregrinas con respecto al
coronavirus desde teorías de la
conspiración hasta tratamientos mágicos
pues atentos a la receta de lukashenko
para luchar contra el kobe 19
el vodka y saunas curarán el coronavirus
dice el presidente de bielorrusia
mientras se niega a confinar el país
como veis algunos estereotipos de la
antigua unión soviética parece que no
terminan de desaparecer también dijo
aunque de esto han pecado muchos otros
gobernantes que el coronavirus no iba a
afectar a bielorrusia y llamó a la
pandemia una psicosis global si lo
habéis oído bien desde el primer momento
lukashenko tuvo muy claro que esto de el
coronavirus no iba con él incluso instó
a los vuelos rusos a dejar de llevar la
mascarilla y por eso mientras que medio
mundo se estaba confiando en sus casas
bielorrusia organizó eventos
multitudinarios como el desfile del 9 de
mayo que ha pasado después pues nada que
no fuera de esperar casi 70 mil
contagios en un país de sólo 9 millones
de habitantes y entre ellos el mismísimo
lukashenko
como os podéis imaginar en cualquier
país estas cifras tendrían un impacto en
la popularidad del presidente verdad
pues sí y a la vez no lo sabemos porque
los estudios sociológicos en bielorrusia
están prácticamente prohibidos de hecho
las organizaciones que quieran llevar a
cabo sondeos políticos tienen que contar
con la aprobación del gobierno y muchas
veces no pueden publicar los resultados
ahora bien este año varios medios
intentaron hacer una encuesta política
online y adivinad lo que ha pasado pues
dos cosas la primera que lukashenko ha
sacado un 3% en la intención de voto y
la segunda que el gobierno ha prohibido
las encuestas electorales
por supuesto que esas encuestas tampoco
eran del todo fiables es difícil pensar
que él lukashenko tenga sólo un 3% de
apoyo todavía cuenta con un montón de
partidarios en las zonas rurales pero es
difícil creerse que en plena crisis del
cobi 19 lukashenko haya ganado las
elecciones con un 80 por ciento y es que
por más que el régimen lo quiera mostrar
así
lukashenko no es ni de lejos la única
opción en las elecciones de 2020
compitió por el puesto con otros cuatro
candidatos y de esos cuatro candidatos
sólo una ha podido llegar a las urnas
hablamos de svetlana tejanos caya
esta mujer se presentó en vez de su
marido porque al marido le metieron en
la cárcel en mayo de este año su delito
será youtuber crítico con el gobierno
los otros dos candidatos tampoco han
podido presentarse a los comicios y en
todos los casos hablamos de presión por
parte del gobierno y por eso toda la
oposición bielorrusa ha cerrado filas en
torno a la señora texana oscar ya su
propuesta electoral es muy clara una
transición a la democracia
básicamente tejanos acá ya quiere
gobernar nueve meses hasta convocar
nuevas elecciones durante esos nueve
meses ya ha prometido que liberará a
todos los presos políticos y convocará
unos comicios limpios y transparentes
como habéis podido adivinar este
programa no le hace la más mínima gracia
a alexander lukashenko lo que seguro que
no habréis adivinado son los argumentos
que ha dado para atacar a su opositor
atentos nuestra constitución no está
hecha para una mujer y nuestra sociedad
no es lo suficientemente madura para
votar a una mujer porque en nuestra
constitución el presidente
a un gran poder habéis oído bien la
frase es literal como podéis ver las
elecciones en bielorrusia no tienen nada
que ver con las de ningún otro lugar en
europa y lo mismo ocurre con el recuento
lukashenko ha obtenido el 80 por ciento
del voto frente al 10% de tejanos kaia
como os podéis imaginar en estas
elecciones hemos visto un catálogo
completo de todas las formas que existen
para manipular unas elecciones se previó
la entrada a los observadores
internacionales durante el día de los
comicios internet se apagó en todo el
país y varios periodistas críticos
fueron expulsados de bielorrusia durante
la campaña
[Música]
al día siguiente los opositores a
lukashenko que obviamente son más del 10
por ciento de los votantes salieron a la
calle a protestar hasta aquí nada que os
vaya a sorprender lo que hace que este
caso sea tan especial son los números
más de doscientas mil personas han
salido a la calle en mins esto es 1 de
cada 10 habitantes además pensad que
hablamos de una dictadura donde existe
la pena de muerte de hecho más de 6.700
manifestantes están ya en la cárcel y
tres de ellos han fallecido a manos de
la policía es decir que salir a
protestar en bielorrusia es todo un
deporte de riesgo el hecho de que más de
200.000 personas se atrevan a
manifestarse indica que hay muchísimos
más que se han quedado en casa y diréis
y qué ha pasado con la opositora de
lukashenko lo que ha pasado con la
señora texana oscar ya pues esto
y observaron chica bosque en este vídeo
se puede ver como la el líder de la
oposición
svetlana pija nobbs acá ya está sentada
en un despacho de la comisión electoral
central está leyendo un papel en el que
dice que las protestas deberían cesar y
que los manifestantes tienen que aceptar
la victoria de lukashenko y si es
exactamente lo que parece la toma de una
rehén recordad que el marido de tijuana
obs kaia sigue en la cárcel bielorrusa
sus hijos han recibido amenazas de
muerte y además varios miembros de su
equipo también estaban detenidos en el
momento en el que esta mujer grabó este
vídeo es más el mismo día en el que se
publicó llegaba este otro anuncio
[Música]
es decir la natilla no está ya está a
salvo está en lituania líneas linke
vicious ministro de asuntos exteriores
de lituania
desde entonces dejamos acá ya sigue en
lituania pero no ha abandonado sus
aspiraciones políticas al contrario ha
anunciado que está preparada para
liderar un gobierno en el exilio es más
incluso ha creado un consejo de
coordinación para la transición
democrática como era de esperar a
lukashenko todo esto no le ha gustado
para nada así que tanto tejano australia
como su equipo podrían ser juzgados por
atentar contra la seguridad nacional de
bielorrusia y todo esto explica que
tanto la unión europea como canadá como
reino unido no reconozcan estos
resultados
las elecciones del 9 de agosto de 2020
están consideradas como un fraude por
casi todos los países del mundo y
viviréis quienes aceptan los resultados
pues en esta lista tenemos a países tan
democráticos como china tayikistán y por
supuesto rusia la madre rusia
y ya sé lo que estabais pensando y raro
que lleváramos tantos minutos sin haber
mencionado a putin pensando bien rusia y
bielorrusia son países hermanos en los
años 90 llegaron a plantearse unirse en
el mismo país parte del gas y el
petróleo que llega desde rusia a europa
pasa por las tuberías de bielorrusia y
putin y lukashenko han sido grandes
amigos durante décadas
[Música]
así que la pregunta es qué va a hacer
putin en este caso defender a lukashenko
mandará al ejército ruso a minsk para
frenar las protestas la respuesta a esta
pregunta es también la respuesta a otra
pregunta aún más importante de verdad
puede bielorrusia a convertirse en una
democracia pues ahora mismo lo vamos a
ver
[Música]
el mal menor os lo contamos hace unas
semanas aquí en visual político desde
principios del año 2020 las relaciones
entre putin y lukashenko han pasado de
'hermanos de sangre' a es complicado la
gran aspiración de rusia desde los años
90 es anexionarse bielorrusia pero
recordad que lukashenko es un megalómano
es ese villano de película de james bond
no es el clásico dictador que acepta ser
un títere de nadie más mucho menos que
el país del que es dictador deje de
existir así que que ha hecho putin al
respecto pues putin ha estado
presionando le como mejor sabe hacer
amenazando con cortar el suministro de
gas y petróleo al país exacto lo mismo
que hemos visto en ucrania todos estos
movimientos podrían haber funcionado con
un líder mínimamente racional pero no
olvidéis que hablamos de un señor como
alexander lukashenko
un director bigelow y de hecho fue en
ese momento en el año 2020 cuando
lukashenko rompió la baraja y amenazó a
putin con robar el petróleo ruso que
pasa por los oleoductos bien los rusos
dicho de otra forma rusia vende petróleo
a europa ese petróleo va por unas
tuberías que pasan por territorio
bielorruso en cualquier momento
bielorrusia podría pinchar estas
tuberías y quedarse con todo ese zumo de
dinosaurio pero no sólo eso
lukashenko se ha estado reuniendo con la
casa blanca de nuevo esto lo
explicábamos con más detalle en un vídeo
que os dejo en la descripción pero
quedaos con este dato en el momento en
el que hacemos este vídeo la unión
europea' ha dicho que no reconoce el
resultado de bielorrusia y por otro lado
la unión europea ha suavizado muchas de
las sanciones a bielorrusia y lo lleva
haciendo desde el año 2016 para el
kremlin todo esto significa una cosa
lukashenko está pactando con el enemigo
y no es de fiar y esta es la primera
gran diferencia entre bielorrusia y
ucrania en el año 2014
ucrania estaba gobernada por víctor
yanukóvich un hombre leal al kremlin
podía ser un corrupto o un autoritario y
lo que vosotros queráis pero era un
hombre racional no se puede decir lo
mismo de alexander lukashenko y por eso
tantos analistas políticos se empiezan a
plantear este escenario
opinión putin quiere que bielorrusia
esté en la órbita de moscú con o sin
lukashenko por supuesto que rusia ha
reconocido el resultado electoral
de hecho putin llamó a lukashenko la
misma noche de las elecciones para darle
la enhorabuena hasta aquí el fin de las
declaraciones en el momento en el que
grabamos este vídeo el kremlin no ha
dicho ni una palabra de mandar a su
ejército para defenderse de las
protestas y creedme en estos momentos
lukashenko necesita ayuda y por mucho
que diga no
lukashenko dice que putin ha prometido
apoyo de seguridad a bielorrusia y lo
cierto es que lukashenko necesitaría ese
apoyo más que nunca para que os hagáis
una idea en pleno 2020 tanto el ejército
como la policía bielorrusa siguen usando
armamento de la unión soviética durante
años este país ha hablado de renovar su
ejército pero más allá de algún programa
muy concreto sigue como estaba en los
años 90 se sentían demasiado cómodos
teniendo la ayuda de rusia sin embargo
ese apoyo incondicional de putin ya no
está garantizado y ya sé lo que estaréis
pensando muchos pero de verdad va a
permitir rusia hacia bielorrusia tengo
un gobierno anti ruso
menuda frase acabo de soltar pero aquí
viene mi pregunta y a vosotros que nos
ha dicho que la oposición a lukashenko
tenga algo en contra de moscú os ha
estallado a la cabeza os va a estallar
la cabeza es atentos
[Música]
la oposición bielorrusa dice que aboga
por una relación amistosa con rusia y
otros países para que os hagáis una idea
uno de esos cuatro candidatos de
oposición era el señor víctor babar ica
directivo de gazprom en biolorrusia más
concretamente este hombre era el
director del banco de gazprom en
bielorrusia y por si no lo sabéis
gazprom es la gasística rusa totalmente
conectada a cómputo
en otras palabras que putin tiene dos
alternativas una es mandar a su ejército
a defender a un dictador que ha
traicionado su confianza
la otra es sentarse y esperar sigan a
lukashenko la situación sigue como esta
si gana la oposición democrática todo
apunta a que las relaciones con rusia
podrían mejorar y diréis venga ya
fonseca eso es imposible putin no puede
permitir que un país aliado se convierta
en una democracia y lo cierto es que os
equivocáis puede que os sorprenda pero
no es la primera vez que un líder
democrático apoya a putin lo hemos visto
ya en armenia
[Música]
la revolución de 2018 de la que ya os
hablamos también en visual política
trajo una transición democrática en este
país tanto el actual presidente como el
actual primer ministro armenio han
cambiado el régimen de arriba a abajo es
más incluso están proponiendo cambiar la
constitución del país en este caso putin
evitó intervenir podría haber mandado al
ejército para mantener al régimen
armenio incluso podría haber hecho como
en ucrania mandar a soldados sin bandera
los famosos hombrecillos verdes pero
decidió quedarse de brazos cruzados y
hoy en día armenia está pasando por una
transición democrática pero sigue siendo
un aliado de rusia y las relaciones con
putin son igual de buenas que antes de
la revolución algo parecido podría
ocurrir en una hipotética transición
bielorrusa es más no sería raro pensar
que rusia podría tener más influencia en
unas elecciones libres que en una
dictadura
pensando bien en un país como
bielorrusia apenas hay medios de
comunicación hablamos de un país de
menos de 10 millones de habitantes que
lleva 24 años sumido en una dictadura
donde obviamente no había libertad de
expresión el kremlin tiene una inmensa
maquinaria de propaganda desde rusia
today hasta los bots de internet bien
utilizada esta maquinaria podría servir
para impulsar a un candidato prorruso en
otras palabras que a putin podría
interesarle quitarse de medio a
lukashenko y todo esto explica que a
diferencia de lo que ocurrió en ucrania
en 2014 ahora putin diga estas cosas
sobre bielorrusia
putin le dice merkel que la intervención
extranjera en los asuntos de los rusos
es inaceptable sin embargo días más
tarde de la conversación con angela
merkel el 27 de agosto
vladimir putin ha anunciado en la
televisión rusa que tiene un comando de
fuerzas especiales listo para actuar si
la situación se descontrola todavía no
sabemos si son solamente palabras o si
rusia estaría realmente dispuesta a
intervenir lo que sí podemos decir es
que en su duelo contra putin
lukashenko ya ha perdido nadie puede
predecir el futuro nadie puede estar en
la cabeza del señor vladimir putin y
desde luego visual político no tenemos
una bola de cristal para predecir el
futuro así que ahora la pregunta es para
vosotros creéis que la oposición
bielorrusa conseguirá derrocar a
lukashenko puede ser este el inicio de
la democracia en bielorrusia podéis
dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y no olvidéis visitar
megaproyectos nuestro nuevo canal de
youtube en el que hablamos de los
proyectos de ingeniería más grandes de
la historia de la humanidad le hemos
puesto un montón de cariño y espera
que lo disfrutéis tanto como nosotros si
os ha gustado este vídeo dadle a like y
nos vemos en el próximo un abrazo y
hasta pronto
[Música]